[Music]
oh yeah one more time
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for is one more time
[Music]
do it
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
who knows
[Music]
it's
[Music]
watching
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
yeah is
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that's too nice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
shut it down
[Music]
that tonight's gonna be a good night
that tonight's gonna be a good night
that's a nice corner
[Music]
is
[Music]
let's do
[Music]
here
up and down
[Music]
friday
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
don't believe me
[Music]
wait a minute
[Music]
nevada please give a warm welcome for
congresswoman titus
[Music]
you can't see my face but i am smiling
to see all of you
here thank you so much i'm dean of titus
and i am proud to represent
the heart of las vegas you are in
district 1 and you are on the campus
where i've taught for 35 years
thank you unlv welcome to all of you
thank you for being here
you know i want us to start first by
wishing the president
and the first lady a full and speedy
recovery
our thoughts were with them but they are
also with all the patients
and their families who are trying to
deal with this virus for no fault of
their own
now is a good time to remind all of us
to wear these masks do special
distancing
wash your hands as much as possible and
we'll come out
stronger on the other side if we are in
this together
so thank you for doing that
and thank you to the baden harris
campaign
for following those kinds of rules for
the good not of themselves
but for all of us so that's why we're
doing this
you know i love the campaign season i
love going out there
shaking hands kissing babies seeing
friends around the district
so this is a new approach this drive-in
rally i guess it just gives
[Music]
all the way to the white house it's been
a very difficult time
in this community whenever the economy
is hit nationally
las vegas gets the worst out of it uh
we've seen just recently that more
hotels and airlines are laying off
people
small businesses are closing i get about
a hundred calls in my office every day
people who want help with unemployment
credit
and mortgage assistants what about food
banks
people are suffering right now but those
of us who've lived here for a while
know that in las vegas we're tough we're
a vegas strong
and we are resilient
we have proven it before and we'll prove
it again
so thank you for all of you who are on
the front lines
helping us get through this we'll come
out stronger on the other side because
we're going to have
new leaders who will help us build back
better joe biden and pamela harris
just think how many lives and jobs could
have been saved
if we had a comprehensive plan from the
beginning
and wouldn't have had to go through all
of this for such a long time
fortunately here in nevada we had
governor steve sislak
who listened to the science
[Music]
he had to make some very hard decisions
but because of his leadership we are
getting through this
and now he's taking time to be with us
today because he knows how important
this election is
thank you governor sislak
[Music]
you know this election is not just about
getting the virus under control
or bringing back our jobs it's about
giving our essential employees
the pay that they deserve and the
protection that they need to be on the
front lines for us
it's about ensuring that the symbol of
the united states
is the statute of liberty and not some
broken down wall that's going to
not keep people out anyway
[Music]
this election is about honoring the
people
who we lost on october the 1st are
taking
action against gun violence not just
with empty thoughts and prayers
and this election is about confronting
climate change because we
just don't have enough time to put this
off and pretend like it doesn't exist
[Music]
and this election is about addressing
systemic racism
not given marching orders to white
supremacist groups
yes that is what is at stake
you know i was one of the first members
to endorse joe biden
back when no votes have been cast and
there were enough democratic candidates
that couldn't even get all on one stage
when i made that decision because
of
knows us he has the depth of knowledge
the breadth of experience and the
strength of conviction
to bring this country back together
he has a plan to address the virus
and restore our economy
he knows what it's like to suffer
personal hardship and has empathy for
those
of us who go through it too and he
agrees with me
that being progressive means making
progress
and getting things done and that's what
i see in him and i think
[Music]
because he can't get there without your
help
we've all got to pitch in you know you
keep hearing the most important election
of your lifetime well this time it
really really really is the most
important election
so we've got to all get out however you
want to vote
vote early vote for mail drop off your
ballot go on election day
however you want to do it make a plan
and go and vote
and take your neighbors take your family
take your sunday school teacher take
your hairdresser
drag anybody you can to the polls
because casting that vote
is so important and you can start right
now
by texting joe easy to spell j-o-e
text joke to 3-0-3-3-0
get out of those cell phones and thanks
joe to 30330
that's how we're going to make a change
and that's how we're going to elect
joe biden and kamala harris
and speaking of karma harris we have a
very special wonderful guest with us
here
in nevada today i want you to help me
welcome her
you're a warm warm welcome because she
is exactly
the kind of dynamic exciting partner
that joe biden needs to get this done
both in the election and in the
government
[Music]
she has never hesitated to take on
powerful people
or powerful interests she is wicked
smart
deeply compassionate and has proven to
be a force
in the senate she comes from california
and has affectionately said we're close
by
so nevada's like her first cousin didn't
get any better than that
she's already making history
she's going to be an outstanding vice
president
she is a friend of ours she is a great
partner
to joe biden give her a warm welcome
senator kamala harris
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all you do what
thank you all thank you everybody
oh wow okay first of all there's so many
incredible leaders who are part of this
afternoon
and who have been a part of this
campaign from the beginning and
we're going to count on them to lead us
through these next 32 days to victory
but i want to thank them
shelby parks our field organizer
organizers
senators jackie rosen and catherine
they were gonna be here but they wanted
to stay in dc because they're fighting
to bring home the leaps to nevada
and they are waging a good fight they
are fighting
to make sure we take care of working
people in america
i want to thank unlv for hosting us
today
um mariachi fiera um jay mesino
everybody for the work that you do
all right so here is this working there
we go
there is so much at stake in this
election
there is so much at stake and we've got
32 days to get this done
and we're gonna get it done and here's
the thing
this campaign our campaign as joe
says is about fighting for the soul of
our nation
and when we talk about when joe talks
about fighting for the soul of our
nation
it's about fighting for working people
it's about fighting for families
it's about fighting for children it's
about fighting for health care
it's about fighting for good union jobs
it's about fighting to preserve our
climate
and clean air and clean water it's about
fighting for a pathway to citizenship
for our brothers and sisters
and renewing protections under daca
there is so much on the line in this
election
and there is not a thing we can take for
granted
not a thing we can take for granted we
are here fighting for the soul of our
nation saying
yes we can get criminal justice reform
and policing reform
yes we can do what is necessary to bring
health care to everybody
because we believe access to health care
should be a right and not just a
privilege of those who can afford it
these are the things that are on the
line in this election
and we've got 32 days to get it done and
i don't need to tell my cousins in
nevada
about the change we see coming
with the work we are doing the change we
see coming when we know here in nevada
we have the highest unemployment of any
state in the country
when there has been incredible
devastation
because of a failure of an
administration to take
seriously a public health crisis
and then do what is necessary to support
working people
but we see the change coming
but we know it will not come without our
investment in this fight
we have a vision of the future
our campaign and the work the hard work
the sacrifice we will make over the next
32 days
is born out of knowing what is possible
and that is so much bigger than fighting
against
something it's about the fight we're in
for something for the people
all the people
that's what our fight is about
and the thing about it and this is what
i love about joe
you know you can talk about how you
measure strength
you know some people say well look at my
muscles you know yeah
it might be one way but the thing that i
love about joey i mean
he could also say yeah look at my
muscles but
the thing about joe is that he
understands the greatest strength
that any of us that any human being has
is displayed when we lift up the
condition of other people
that's the strength of who we are
the strength of who we are and therefore
the power
of the people is knowing that when we
are together
when we are joined when we are unified
when we don't allow people to try and
divide us and turn on each other
we are strong we are strong
and so in spite of all we've been
experiencing folks
don't let anybody make you feel alone
don't let any circumstance make you feel
isolated because we are all in this
together we are all in this together
[Music]
but to achieve the change we can see
coming
we got a vote we got a vote
and so what do we want to do honk if
you're going to vote early
[Music]
how if you're gonna vote by mail
honk if you're gonna make sure at least
five people you know don't vote
ten people you know
and here's the thing none of us are
immune we've been reading it we know
what's going on around the country
there's some powerful people in our
country
that are trying to make it difficult for
folks to vote did you guys see what
happened in texas yesterday
the governor of texas republican
governor of texas
basically started getting rid of the
drop boxes in texas
yeah that's what they're doing so here's
the thing
you know the right to vote the right to
vote
was a hard fought and a hard one right
in fact one of the biggest events that i
attended before the pandemic struck
was to walk across the edmund pettus
bridge
in alabama with now the great ancestor
john lewis
who shed his blood on that bridge
for the white for folks to vote
we honor the ancestors when we vote just
last month
we celebrated the 100th anniversary of
the 19th amendment
when those suffragettes those powerful
women
marched and fought for the right for
women in america to vote
we also recognize that it wasn't until
1965 that black women could vote
so we know there is still work to do and
that we are a country
of work in progress
but this is the history of our route to
vote our right to vote was a hard
fought and one right
which we will never let anybody take
from us but we know there are
obstacles around the country being put
in a way
we know there are powerful people trying
to suggest that you can't trust the
process
trying to suggest it's rigged or it's
this or it's that
but we know better we know better
and here's the thing i want to also
point out
at some point in addition to voting it's
got to be about honoring the ancestors
in addition to voting it has to be about
knowing what's at stake
and also we've got to just sit back
sometimes and ask
why are so many powerful people
trying to mess with our right to vote
like just sit back and ask that for a
minute why are so many powerful people
going through such difficulty
to try and mess with our right to vote
and here's what i believe the answer is
because they know when we vote
things change
they know when we vote things get better
and so nevada never let anybody take
your power we will
not let anybody take our power we will
use our power we will
vote we know our vote is our voice we
know what is at stake
and we know we are all in this together
in this fight for the soul of our nation
and it is a fight born out of love of
our country
knowing what can be unburdened
by what has been thank you nevada
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bring this home let's hear
the things that everybody told me would
never happen but godless boys
[Music]
is
[Music]
because
[Music]
all right